why do we need the old testament
if we believe in jesus who is the god
of the new testament why do we need the
old testament
if we have jesus who is the god
of the new testament let me say
immediately
that jesus is the god of the bible
amen not just the old testament but let
me take you to the word of god very
directly
and show you that the old testament
is as essential as the new testament
and to ignore the old testament is to
ignore christ let us go to first
corinthians chapter 10
we shall read from verse one our subject
is
questions questions questions
and do not hesitate to shout out slowly
please
because you know what my habit is to go
too fast i got an email today that said
please pastor
can you speak slowly i have a friend
whose first language is not english
and i have always to keep that in mind
because i keep
forgetting because you speak it so well
first corinthians 10 reading from verse
moreover brethren i would not that he
should be ignorant
how all our fathers were under the cloud
and all pass through the sea and were
all baptized
unto moses in the cloud and in the sea
and it all eat the same spiritual meat
now verse 4 is critical
and then all drink the same spiritual
drink
for the drink of that spiritual rock
that followed them
finished the verse and that rock go on
loudly
was christ now the bible is very clear
the rock from which the israelites drank
represented christ the divine presence
that followed the israelites all through
the wilderness wanderings
was christ the bible says for they drank
of that spiritual rock
that followed them and that rock
was christ if you throw out
the old testament you throw out christ
let's keep reading verse 5
but with many of them god was not well
pleased
for they were overthrown in the
wilderness
now these are our examples to the intent
we should not lust after evil things as
they also lusted who is
they the israelites in the wilderness
in other words what happened to them we
must study
because their experiences are examples
for us
that we should avoid what they did there
is a saying
experience is the best teacher but let
it be
someone else's experience not yours
don't get drunk to know what drunkness
is like don't take drugs to know what
addiction is like
don't commit crime to know what it is
like learn from
other people's experience so these
things were our examples to the intent
for six
we should not lust after evil things as
they
also lusted now here comes four examples
of things they lusted after mistakes
they may that we should avoid
neither be idolaters as were some of
them
as it is written the people sat down to
eat and drink
and rose up to play and that's found in
exodus 32
between verse five and six neither let
us commit fornication
as some of them committed and fell in
one day
three and twenty thousand now verse 9
neither let us tell christ
as some of them also tempted
and were destroyed of serpents the bible
says
when the israelites gave god a hard time
in the old testament
the person they were irritating was
christ
now listen to the verse again verse 9
first corinthians 10
am i going too quickly all right i'm
close to it let me
back off neither let us
tempt christ the word tempt means to
really try
the patience of god to push god to the
limit
as some of them also tempted
and were destroyed of serpents when did
this happen
keep your finger on first corinthians 10
verse 9
let us go to numbers 21 we shall read
verses 5 and 6.
we want to identify the incident
when they were destroyed by serpents
because they tempted whom
christ numbers 21 reading from verse 5
and the people spake against god and
against moses
let me pause be very careful how you
criticize your leaders
someone genuinely elected by the church
is in that position by the will of god
when you attack
that person when you attack that office
you attack god
i'm not saying you must agree with
everything people do i am
saying when you try to undermine
leadership of the church
when you constantly attack leadership of
the church when you damage a person's
influence by what you say to the members
you are attacking god
listen to verse 5 numbers 21 and the
people
speak against god and against moses
because
moses was elected by god the church is
the body of christ
when officers are elected they must be
respected
even though we disagree
and the people speak against god and
against moses
wherefore have he brought us up out of
egypt to die
in the wilderness for there's no bread
and there's no water
and our in love with this light bread
the light bread being the manna verse
six
read for six with me and whom the lord
sent what
fiery serpents among the people and they
bit the people
and much people of israel die now the
bible says the lord
said the serpents but the new testament
tells us who the lord was
and who was that tell me jesus christ
now we go back to first corinthians
chapter 10
verse 9 neither let us tempt christ
as some of them also tempted and were
destroyed of serpents
so we have two verses first corinthians
10 4
the rock that followed them was christ
first corinthians
10 9 the god they irritated was christ
let us go to hebrews chapter 11 we shall
read verse 24
and 25 or 24 to 26
hebrews 11 24-26 our subject is
questions questions questions we're
answering the questions why do we need
the old testament
when christ is the god of the new
testament and i responded immediately by
saying
christ is the god of the bible not just
the old testament
because second timothy chapter 3 verse
16 says
all scripture is given by inspiration of
god
and it's profitable for doctrine
for reproof for correction for
instruction in righteousness how much
scripture
all scripture is given by inspiration
all scripture is profitable now we're in
hebrews 11
24 the bible says by faith moses
when he was come to years refused to be
called the son
of pharaoh's daughter choosing rather to
suffer affliction
with the people of god that they enjoyed
the pleasures of sin for a season
verse the next verse esteeming the
reproach of whom
christ greater riches than the treasures
in egypt
for he had respect until recompense of
the reward when moses
chose the sight of god's people moses
decided i will
accept any reproach for the name of
christ
esteeming the reproach of christ
moses was aware that that power that
spoke to him in the burning bush
that declared the law on sinai that was
the rock that followed them
the water that came from the rock the
pillar of fire by night to keep them
warm
the pillar of cloud by dare to keep them
cool from the burning sun in the desert
that was christ amen
discard the old testament and you
discard jesus christ
let's go again to first peter chapter
one
first peter one we shall read from verse
nine
first peter chapter one reading verse
nine i was told also by a distinguished
leader of the church
i don't give you enough time to find the
verses
so i repent in sackcloth and ashes and
ask you now have you found first peter
chapter one
reading from verse nine receiving the
end of your faith
even the salvation of your souls of
which salvation the prophets have
inquired and searched diligently
who prophesied of the grace that shall
come unto you searching what verse 11
and what manner of time now peter is
saying the old testament prophets
wrote about salvation that christ was to
bring in person
notice i said bring in person salvation
function from the time adam sinned but
christ came in person
and so verse 11 searching what
or what manner of time the spirit of
christ which was in them did signify
when it testified beforehand the
suffering of christ
and the glory that should be revealed
the bible is clear
the spirit that inspired the old
testament
was whose spirit the spirit of christ
now explain to me how do you get rid of
the old testament
you're getting rid of christ
[Music]
first corinthians 10 4 the rock that
followed them was christ
first corinthians 10 9 the god they made
angry
was christ hebrews 11 verse 25
26 moses accepted the reproach of christ
first peter 1 verse 11 the spirit that
inspired isaiah
jeremiah all those old testament
prophets was
the spirit of christ my brothers and
sisters
if you get rid of the old testament you
are getting rid
of christ listen again to our scripture
reading
second timothy chapter 3 verse 16
all scripture what does that include
the old testament all in you all
scripture
is given by whom
inspiration of god
to dump the old testament is to dump a
gift
from god all scripture
is given by inspiration of god and
is profitable for
doctrine one of the reasons why people
don't accept doctrines as they should
they do not go to the old testament
any doctrine in the new has its roots in
the old
yes let me say that again there is no
doctrine in the new testament
that has its root in the new testament
whether salvation forgiveness repentance
the second coming of christ
state of the dead the sabbath the law is
judgment
you choose the doctrine it's root
is in the old testament so all scripture
is given by inspiration of god and is
profitable
for doctrine for reproof for correction
and for instruction in righteousness
that the man of god may be what perfect
thoroughly furnished unto all good works
all that he needs
to live a life of good works in the eyes
of god is found in the old and in the
new when you discard the old
you have discarded some of what the man
of god
needs
if you've thrown it away get it back
listen to john 5 39.
i'll let you find it our subject
question questions questions
the first question we're dealing with
why do we need the old testament
when christ is the god of the new god
christ the holy spirit they are god of
the bible
do you have john 5 39 search the
scriptures
now when jesus said that what scripture
was he referring to because the new had
not yet been written
he said search the scriptures for
in them you think he have eternal life
and they
are they which testify
of me so jesus says you want to learn
about me
go to the scriptures and all the
scriptures he had was the old testament
when you get rid of the old testament
you get rid of a source of knowledge
that jesus recommends
if that's clear somebody say amen
search the scriptures for if they think
he have eternal life
and they are they which testify of me
my brothers and sisters the bible
is the old and the new
the same way people were saved in the
new testament
they were saved in the old testament
there's only one way to be saved
and that is by faith in jesus christ
so you read hebrews chapter 11 verse 7
by faith noah being warned of god
of things not seen as yet moved with
fear
prepared an ark to the saving of his
house by which he condemned the world
and became the heir of the righteousness
which is by faith
noah was saved by faith
by faith abraham verse 17 when he was
tried
offered up isaac abraham was saved
by faith even earlier verse 4 by faith
abel offered unto god a more excellent
sacrifice than cain
by faith abel was accepted verse 5
by faith enoch was translated that he
should not see death
and was not found because god had
translated him
by faith enoch was saved
by faith in the old by
faith in the new the only difference was
christ had not yet come in the earth in
person
he came in the new in person but every
lamb
sacrifice in the old testament was a
symbol of the land that was to come is
that clear
please get back to the old testament if
you have thrown it
away question number two
why do i have to keep the law if i
am under what grace
oh by the way before i get into that
well let me get into it
there is only one reason why people try
to throw away the old testament
one one
and it's because of one chapter
can you guess what that chapter is what
chapter is that
exodus chapter 20 which contains what
the ten commandments that's why people
throw away the entire old testament
they are trying to get rid of
the law now let's be more specific
people say we do not have to keep the
law we're under grace
they are trying to get rid of the
sabbath because the people who say
i am under grace i don't have to keep
the law they
want you to obey the law that says thou
shalt not kill
tell me if i'm right they have they want
you to obey the lord and says thou shalt
not take my wife commit adultery
what they are really targeting is the
sabbath commandment
but to get rid of it they say we don't
need the law
to get rid of the ten commandments as a
whole they say we don't need the old
testament
you keep that up you'll eventually come
to the place where you say we don't need
what
in the entire bible if you live long
enough
and you step on that path i don't need
the old testament
i don't need the law you come to the
place inevitably
where you conclude i don't need the
bible
but god of this mercy cuts people off
before they reach a point
of no return in their rejection of truth
why do i have to keep the law
if i am under grace go to romans chapter
6 we read verses 14
and 15 of romans chapter 6.
you're not telling me to slow down you
should
so if i rush off like a train and
someone doesn't understand
i will point the person to you
to explain it'll be your fault not mine
what book did i say what chapter
1 verse 14 for sin
shall not not have dominion over you for
year one
not under the but under
now paul says that in one verse which a
lot of christians love to read
ah you see we are not under the law
we're under grace but they do not read
the very
next verse read it out loud with me
what then shall we because we're not
under the
but under finish the verse god forbid
now
what is sin now okay read verse 15 again
using that uh definition read nice and
loud come on
what then shall we no no no no
what is sin now read verse 15 using that
what then shall we transgress the law
go on because we're under grace and not
under the law
god forbid
what does god forbid me
[Music]
are you with me god forbid
that your position under grace gives you
the right to break the law
well romans 3 31
i believe it's romans 3 31. if it's not
romans 3 31 is
romans 3 31 what does that verse say
do we then do what make for the law
through
faith yeah we do what establish the law
now faith must be used twice even though
it's mentioned once
do we then make for the law through
faith god forbid here
we establish the law through faith even
though that's not written that's what
the writer means
faith in god is the means by which
we establish his law my brothers and
sisters
any man under grace finds the law
as an expression of love for his savior
being under the law means under the
condemnation
of the law when i see a policeman i am
pleased
you know why he represents order
he represents uh protection from harm
and hurt
when a criminal sees a policeman he
tries to hide
why because he is under the condemnation
of the law that's why the bible says the
law was not
made for a righteous man in other words
it was not emphasized
written on stone for a righteous man
because a righteous man
is a law-abiding man
[Music]
are you with me if you drive through a
neighborhood
nice neighborhood nice clean lawns nice
walls nice houses
very clean and neat you don't put it
beside please don't throw garbage on the
ground
because there's none oh yes now you go
through a neighborhood with garbage all
over the place what do you do
you put up a sign please pick up your
garbage are you with me
so that there's no lawn needed for the
neat clean neighborhood
because they do it naturally but for the
neighborhood where people throw things
all over the place
there must be a law pick it up
for the person who truly loves christ in
whose heart christ dwells
no law needs to be written the law comes
out
of the heart and so the bible says the
law is not written
for a righteous man it is written for
a sinner the word written means
emphasized
in connection with i am under grace not
on the law therefore i break the law
go to jeremiah 31 let's read verse 33
because in connection with that is the
claim some christians make
i am a new covenant christian
i don't have to keep the law i am a new
covenant christian
let's look at the new covenant as
prophesied by jeremiah
jeremiah 1 31 reading verse 33
but this shall be the covenant that i
will make with the house of israel
after this day save the lord i will put
my law where
in the inward part and write it where in
their hearts
and will be their god and there shall be
my people
that's a prophetic statement of
something that would be done
now let's go to hebrews chapter 10.
here is paul talking about the
fulfillment of
of jeremiah 31 33 hebrews 10 16
when you have it say amen so i know
i've given you time to find it
all right do we all have hebrews 10 16
for this oh someone said no look in the
new
testament whoever it was that said no
somewhere towards the back of the bible
somebody helped that nice
person find hebrews but since we haven't
got all night we have to press on can
you say amen
hebrews 10 verse 16 what does the bible
say for this shall be the covenant that
i will make with them after those days
save the lord i will do what
put my law in the and right and in their
hearts will i
write them i will put my laws in their
hearts in their mind and
their hearts will i write them now
what law does god write in the heart
under the new testament
the same law he wrote where
on stone in the old
is simply transferred from stone
and put where on the heart
the new covenant does not present a
different set of laws
it is just a different location for the
writing of the law symbolically
under the old testament the law was
written on tables of stone
and kept in the ark through christ
it is written on the heart
which by the way was the way abraham
lived
let me say i hope it doesn't confuse you
everyone who's ever been saved
has been saved by the new covenant
abraham was saved by the new covenant
the law was in his heart
adam noah enoch knew covenant
the law in the heart because of
slavery in egypt they had forgotten god
that's why moses said give me a name
that i may tell them
so god had to take a kindergarten
approach
a primary school approach with visual
aids
the law on tables of stone the sanctuary
visual age for these kindergarten people
but noah abraham seth
all those holy men the law was on the
heart
jesus came to reestablish that under the
old testament
the law was on tables of stone under the
new testament the same law
is written on the heart it is not done
away with it is not changed my brothers
and sisters the
same law but it is written
on the heart so if you are a new
testament christian the law of the old
testament christians were
supposed to keep you and i are required
if we love jesus christ
to keep